[Music]
consider the claw frequently found on
four-limbed
animals around the world it's one of
nature's most versatile tools bears use
claws for digging as well as defense and
eagles needle-like talons can pierce the
skulls of their prey and lions can
retract their massive claws for easy
movement before flicking them out to
hunt even the ancestors of primates used
to wield these impressive appendages
until their claws evolved into nails so
what in our evolutionary past led to
this manicured adaptation and what can
nails do that they're sharper cousins
can't
when nails first appeared in the fossil
record around fifty five point eight
million years ago claws had already been
present for over 260 million years in
the ancestors of mammals and reptiles
but despite the Gulf of time between
their emergence these adaptations are
both part of the same evolutionary story
both nails and claws are made of keratin
a tough fibrous protein also found in
horns scales hooves and hair this
protein is produced by a wedge of tissue
called the keratin matrix rich in blood
vessels and nutrients this protein
factory produces an endless stream of
keratin which is tightly packed into
cells called keratinocytes these
high-density cells give nails and claws
their trademark toughness
since nails evolved from claws both
adaptations produce keratinocytes in the
same way the cells grow out from the
matrix emerging from the skin where they
die and hardened into a water-resistant
sheath the primary difference between
the two keratin coverings is really just
their shape which depends on the shape
of the bone at the end of the animal's
digits in claws the bed of the
keratinocytes conforms to a narrow
finger bone wrapping around the end of
the digit and radiating outwards to form
a cone shaped structure animals with
nails on the other hand have much
broader digits and keratinocytes only
cover the top surface of their wide
bones it's possible that nails have
simply persisted as a side effect of
primates evolving wider more dexterous
fingers but given what we know about the
habitats of our primate ancestors it's
more likely that nails came with their
own powerful advantages hi in the forest
canopy where these primates lived wide
finger bones and expansive finger pads
were ideal for gripping narrow branches
and nails improve that grip even further
by providing a rigid surface to press
against primates could splay out their
pads to create even more contact with
the trees
additionally nails improved the
sensitivity of their digits by providing
an extra surface to detect changes in
pressure while climbing this combination
of sensitivity and dexterity gave our
ancestors the precise motor control
needed to snatch up insects pinched
berries and seeds and keep a firm grip
on slim branches the evolution of nails
and the evolution of opposable thumbs
and toes are closely linked and when our
ancestors moved down from the trees this
flexible grasp enabled them to create
and wield complex tools even if it was
possible for wide fingers to sport claws
their sharp points would have likely
interfered with these primates regular
tasks claws are ideal for piercing Punk
shirring and hooking but their points
make grabbing difficult and potentially
dangerous however both claws and nails
are used in some unexpected ways
manatees use nails to grasp their food
and researchers think elephant toenails
may sense vibrations in the ground to
help them hear meanwhile some primates
like the eye eyes of Madagascar have
reacquired claws they use these extra
long appendages to tap branches and
trunks while listening for hollow
sections with their bat-like ears when
they hear an opening they burrow into
the tree and skewer grubs with their
needle-like middle finger we've only
scratched the surface of all the
incredible ways nails and claws are used
throughout the animal kingdom but as for
which of these adaptations is better
that's an answer we may never nail down
did this lesson leave you scratching
your head about the evolution of the
human body
check out this lesson to understand why
we each
[Music]